[Music]
Tanya get rid of her we decided you were
a tragic heroine in the Opera how did I
not see the signs
[Music]
in the end of last season Tanya is
sitting with Greg in the last episode
and he's talking about his health issues
and she says I've had every kind of
treatment over the years death is the
last immersive experience I haven't
tried and I was thinking it'd be so fun
to bring Tanya back because she's such a
great character but maybe that's the
journey for her as like a journey to
death and not that I really wanted to
kill Tony because I love her as a
character and obviously love Jennifer
but it just felt like you know we're
going to Italy she's such a kind of Diva
Larger than Life female archetype it
just felt like we could
devise our own operatic conclusion to
Tanya's life and her story
thing
dying at the hands of someone else felt
too tragic it felt like she needed to
give her best fight back and that she in
a way had some kind of victory over
whoever was conspiring to get rid of her
so it just made me laugh to think like
she would like take out all of these
cabal of killers and that after she
successfully does that then she just
dies this Derpy death and it just felt
like that's just so Tanya
you've got this
I think as far as like what happens to
Greg and the conspiracy of Tanya's death
it's possible that I think Porsha is
scared enough to just leave it alone but
the fact that all of those guys die on
the boat it feels like there's got to be
somebody who's gonna track it back down
to Greg but maybe you'll have to wait to
find out what happens
at the end of the show you see the three
generations of men and there's this
attractive woman who crosses and they
all sort of gawk at her you know my hope
is that Dominic does change but there is
a little bit in the texture of it that
their relationship with women is going
to always be fraught with the sexual
desire but she hugged me just now I got
a little aroused
no no it's a natural reaction
he kissed me
but that was it okay that was all the
question of like whether Harper and
Camera did more than the kiss I think
probably that's just all that happened
at the same time there's some time that
isn't completely accounted for and I
think that that's why it's like eating
at Ethan
Ethan comes to Daphne and did they have
some kind of little dalliance on the
island or whatever happened it allows
him to let go of the jealousy that has
been brewing with him and it kind of
brings back that first kind of sexual
charge that happens in the beginning of
relationships it sometimes Fades away
over time by the end you're like well
maybe what Ethan and Harper needed was a
small dash of what Cameron and Daphne
have thanks for putting up with me
I love you it feels like Cameron to me
is like one of those guys that's not
really Gonna Change
unspoken things between them you wonder
if that's gonna ultimately catch up with
them it is somewhat of a happy ending
although there's dark clouds in the
Horizon too
the first season kind of highlighted
money and then the second season is sex
and I think the third season it would be
maybe a kind of satirical and funny look
at death in eastern religion and
spirituality and it feels like it could
be a rich tapestry to do another round
at White Lotus
[Music]
foreign